thanks al and thank you for the
invitation it's true it's my first time
in Canada and first time in in Vancouver
and I must say if this is the least
happy city in the country i look forward
to exploring the rest of it I'm
absolutely in love with the city and
I've had great hosts and met great
people but yes it's it's true i come
from Copenhagen where run the the
happiness research institute and as alan
said basically what we try to do is we
try to inform policymakers of causes and
effects of human happiness so we try to
advise how do we create better framework
conditions for better lives so so what I
want to talk to you today is about this
specific study that we did last year
where we try to quantify happiness in a
Danish city or Danish town it's
completely unpronounceable for non
Danish speakers but it's called tower
you can refer to it as the Copenhagen
suburb I want to of course talk about
what we did and what we found in the in
the study but also what the reactions
were and and what I felt or feel that
that we changed in the city for for the
better very briefly about the city it's
one of the smallest municipalities in in
Denmark for 14,000 people over 18 years
it's located close to our capital and
it's it's one of the most affluent ones
in in in the country so what we did was
we try to quantify quality of life on
different dimensions or quantify
happiness both the dimension which is
some time
sometimes referred to as the cognitive
evaluative dimension where we have
respondents sort of take a step back and
evaluate their lives the other dimension
we try to quantify is what is we call it
the effective dimension which is more
about what kind of emotions what kind of
moods do people experience in in their
daily lives so once we have that data we
try to see what are the common
denominators for those people who feel
happy what are the common denominators
for unhappiness what drives these things
and what can we together with the city
do in order to increase happiness for
the citizens so overall the hour the
town does this fairly well sixty-five
percent of the people out there say
eight nine or ten if we ask them how
happy do you feel all in all and this is
consistent with with the picture we see
elsewhere in Denmark the average
happiness level in the city was around
7.8 I actually understood from grant
earlier today vancouver's average is
higher oh that's bad news so you're
you're doing better than then one of the
cities in apparently the happiest
country in the world but fairly good
still on the cognitive dimension also
very good levels when it comes to the
effective dimension a lot of people feel
joy a lot of people feel happiness on a
daily basis we also have of course a
list of issues a list of challenges a
lot of people feel sad anxious but but
to me one of the most concerning numbers
is the one down the bottom I'm not sure
whether you can read it at the back but
it says that one in ten of our citizens
do not see an overall purpose with their
lives and I think it's worrying for two
reasons first I think it's a strong
statement to say I don't see a purpose
with my life to me that would be quite
alarming secondly I would suspect that
the actual number would be even higher
right remember this is from a survey I
think there are some stigma attached to
admitting that you do not see your
purposes with your life so I think the
actual numbers is even higher
the good thing is of course there's some
characteristics with the people who do
see purpose or meaning with their lives
one of them is of course they are an
average happier but they're also much
more inclined to taking part in
community work fifty percent of those
people volunteer in different
organizations only ten fifteen percent
of the ones that do not see a purpose
with their lives volunteer but what we
found was the key challenges coming back
to what what al said earlier is
isolation feeling lonely is a driver of
unhappiness and it's also something that
is quite widespread in our study and
this is consistent with what we see
elsewhere in Denmark fifteen percent say
that they do feel lonely in their
everyday lives another dimension in the
isolation thing is also so that the
quality of relationships that we have
and almost one in ten people in our town
say that there is nobody in their
network they can rely on in times of
need and there's nobody they can discuss
personal matters with and we know that's
an issue because when we look at the
relationship between our relations and
our life satisfaction our happiness it's
a really strong predictor of whether
people are happy or not so in our study
we divided people into four groups
according to how happy they are with
their relationships not at all happy to
some degree or too little degree to some
degree or very much and the number you
see on top of the bar is that groups
average happiness level so those that
are very satisfied with their
relationships average happiness level of
8.3 this number 3.3 the average for
those people that are not at all
satisfied with their social
relationships is the lowest number we
could detect the lowest average for any
group in our study
just for comparison reasons because you
don't look at these numbers every day
there is only countries I mean only
countries that are really poor
politically unstable such as the African
Central African Republic have averages
of around 3.3 and for those of you that
work with statistics the correlation
between our happiness with our social
relationships or satisfaction with our
social relationships and happiness is
almost 0.5 which is sort of a medium
strong relationship so we have a series
of reactions to the city study why
should a city start spending money on
focusing on happiness should a city
interfere with happiness of the citizens
and we've been called anything from
communists to a camp of hippies that's
just trying to spend more resources and
we have one national politician who
wrote use from the right wing in Denmark
hero you know the state shouldn't
interfere with people's happiness it's
up to the people themselves to create
their own happiness and we replied in
the same paper that if you're a national
politician that doesn't think you can
create framework conditions to improve
people's lives then why are you sitting
in Parliament you got a little mad over
that but overall the reactions has been
really good so what we try to do of
course we try to see what can we do in
order to increase the sense of community
relationships for people and and we we
did three things together with the city
first of all we completely eliminated
the fee to the local community center
there's a well-functioning community
center there is anything from bridge to
martial arts to patong but a lot of
people low-income groups were not able
to use the center because there were
fees so we eliminated that the second
initiative was to create more community
gardens or urban gardens it's very
popular in many countries unless you're
also here community gardens are good for
several reasons first of all they're
great to look at in the city it's also
an easy initiative to invite lonely p
into it doesn't carry the same social
stigma as other initiatives do it's
easier to my people in 20 come down down
this August we're going to have as
carrots doesn't hold this social stigma
of you being lonely and that's why we're
inviting you another thing is and that's
the timing issue the activities in the
community gardens take place at the
times where we know loneliness is the
worst spring summer right now what is
happening we're seeing you know
everybody's playing volleyball down by
the beach in Stanley Park everybody is
having out hanging out with their
friends those are the times of year
where lonely people feel lonely Nazz the
hardest because they can see the rest of
the community flourishing the last thing
was that we now have a group of
volunteers youth that are taking some of
our senior citizens around town on
bicycles such as this touring the the
town of sites that is important to our
senior citizens it could be a childhood
home where the senior citizen into
school but coming for all these things
is that they are trying to build tighter
stronger community having people meet
each other from different groups and all
of these initiatives are actually also
they're very simple the very low-tech
their cost efficient and these are just
from from our town we see range of
activities across the world that is
doing just the same and we're trying to
get inspiration for that as well and
that's also why i'm here today to get an
inspiration from you guys so i can bring
back home so we can still keep our first
place in the happiness rankings but just
in your international examples we see in
in the netherlands since 2006 they have
conducted one ish car called the
National neighbor day right so it's
something we actually used to do you
know having coffee with our neighbors
talking over the picket fence and so on
is something we've forgotten to do over
the last decades in Holland now since
2006 they put it on the agenda and you
might say it's funny that we should have
a national day to celebrate that or
become you know do that why don't we
just do it by ourselves but we also have
Christmas a tradition that brings people
together in families we might as well
have one that brings neighbors together
it's a big success in the New Orleans
thousands and thousands of cups of
coffee are being drunk neighbors alike
in Bristol they've conducted a whole
range of activities in the happy city
program one of them has been to hand out
happy city points when they see people
doing something nice to a stranger they
hand out happy city points which you can
purchase coffee in local stores for of
course there's some you know discussion
you know why don't people just do it by
themselves you really want them for
being nice they should just be nice and
that's true as well but I think it's an
interesting and creative initiative and
we can actually also find inspiration in
countries that most of us probably don't
think of of being very happy in
Afghanistan they have what is called the
mobile minute circus for kids and it
teaches them how to perform different
sorts of circus activities it teaches
them how to juggle it teaches them how
to do acrobatics but most importantly it
teaches them to engage in relationships
to be part of a community to enjoy other
people and it teaches them that being
part of something with other people can
create quality of life for themselves
and I think I'm about out of time now
but I look forward to the discussion
afterwards so thank you for listening
you